Nathan I told you you through young to
have a gun they can't have a gun yeah my
god have a gun
no you can't have been either yeah I
know yeah there you go say thank you to
Grandpa well visit makes it okay it'll
always pop it around
you rat Lou pop right guys you ready go
into Cabela's yeah king animals doing
that pop there yeah
[Music]
okay this remember guys don't sabotage
it but the bass in there you guys got to
see down here because last time you
threw fishing lures in in the aquarium
marlis Nathan did makes got jammed in
the filtration system and the fish
attacked it with mud we almost had to
buy Bass Pro a bunch of fish oh no
people need that we so don't need that
thank you yeah that's a Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtle rod plant work done with
it's a
oh yes thank you hey Tom
so you ran off buddy yeah it's a big
bear up there all right this looks fine
Ethan and mommy sorry buddy no net you
literally have that exact net at home I
know that's never stopped me before but
here go up to bed posted a check off
today